let's see if we can draw the lewis
diagram for a nitrate anion so a nitrate
anion has one nitrogen
and three oxygens
and it has a negative charge i'll do
that in another color it has a negative
charge so pause this video and see if
you can draw that the lewis structure
for a nitrate anion
all right well we've done this many
times the first step is to just account
for the valence electrons
nitrogen has one two three four five
valence electrons in its outer shell and
in that second shell if it's a neutral
free nitrogen atom so we have five
valence electrons there
oxygen has one two three four five six
valence electrons but if you have three
oxygens you're going to have six times
three and so if you just add up the
valence electrons if these were free
neutral atoms
you would get 5 plus 18 which is 23
valence electrons
now the next thing we have to keep in
mind is this is an anion this has a
negative one charge right over here so
it's going to have one more
extra electron one more extra valence
electron than you would expect if these
were just free atoms that were neutral
so let's add one valence electron here
so that gets us to 24
valence electrons and then the next step
is let's try to actually draw this
structure and the way we do it is we try
to pick the least electronegative atom
that is not hydrogen to be the central
atom in this case it is nitrogen it's to
the left of oxygen in that second period
so let's put nitrogen in the center
right over there and around it let's put
three oxygens
so
one
two
three oxygens
let's put a single bond between them
and so so far we and let me do that in
another color so we can account for it
better so i'll do them in purple
so so far we have accounted for two four
six valence electrons so minus six
valence electrons gets us to 18 valence
electrons
the next step is we would try to
allocate as many of these as possible to
our terminal atoms the oxygens over here
try to get them to a full octet so let's
do that this each of these oxygens
they're already participating in one of
these covalent bonds so they already
have two valence electrons hanging out
so let's see if we can give them each
another six to get to eight so two
four
six
two
[Music]
four
six
and then 2
4
and 6. and so just like that we have
allocated 18 valence electrons 6 12 18.
so minus 18
valence electrons and we are now left
with no
further valence electrons to allocate
but let's see how our atoms are doing we
know the oxygens have a full octet but
the nitrogen only has two four
six valence electrons hanging around it
would be great if there was a lewis
structure where we could have eight
valence electrons for that nitrogen
well one way to do that is to take one
of these lone pairs from one of the
oxygens and turn that into another
covalent bond so let's do that so let me
just erase this pair right over here
and i'm just going to turn that into
another covalent bond
and this is looking pretty good we have
eight valence electrons around each of
the oxygens and now we have eight for
the nitrogen two four six eight and we
have to remind ourselves that this is an
anion
it has a negative one charge so to
finish the lewis diagram we would just
put that negative charge there and this
is all well and good but if this was the
only way that nitrate existed when we
observed nitrate anions in the world we
would expect to see
one shorter bond and two longer bonds
and we would expect one of the bonds to
have a different energy than the other
two
but in the real world we don't see that
we see that all of the bonds actually
have the same length and they actually
have the same energy
and so an interesting question is why is
that
and one thing that you might appreciate
is when i took that lone pair to create
this covalent bond i could have done it
with that top oxygen i could have done
it with this bottom left oxygen or i
could have done it with that bottom
right oxygen and so there's actually
three valid lewis structures that we
could have had not only could we have
had this lewis structure we could have
had this one and i'll draw it all in
yellow to save us some time where you
have this nitrogen as a single bond with
that top oxygen and so that top oxygen
still has six electrons in lone pairs
and maybe it forms a double bond with
the bottom left oxygen so this bottom
left oxygen only has two lone pairs one
of them would have gone to form the
double bond
and then this oxygen would look the same
so
what i am drawing here is another valid
lewis structure or the double bond might
have formed with this bottom right
oxygen so let me draw
that
so another valid lewis structure could
look like this so nitrogen bonded that
oxygen has three
lone pairs
this oxygen also has
three
lone pairs and now this one has the
double bond and only has two
lone pairs
and whenever we see a situation where we
have three valid lewis structures we
call this resonance
resonance
resonance and we'll put an arrow these
two way arrows between these structures
and when you hear the word resonance it
sometimes conjures up this image that
you're bouncing back you're resonating
between these structures but that's
actually not right what the right way to
think about it is these different ways
of visualizing the nitrate these
contribute to a resonance hybrid which
is really the true way that the nitrate
exists and so if we wanted to draw a
resonance hybrid it would look like this
you have the nitrogen in the center
you have your oxygens one two
three i can draw our first covalent bond
like that and then you would show the
bond between nitrogen and each of these
oxygens are a hybrid between some place
between a single bond and a double bond
and so instead of just one of them
having the double bond and the other two
having single bonds they're all
somewhere in between so maybe you draw a
dotted line something like that to show
what the reality is is that you actually
have three bonds that are someplace in
between a single and a double bond
because the electrons in this molecule
are delocalized throughout and of course
you want to make sure you always want to
make sure that people recognize that
this is a
anion so this is the idea of resonance
you have multiple valid lewis structures
they are all contribute to a resonance
hybrid which is actually what we observe
we're not just bouncing between these
different structures the actual
observation will be a hybrid of the
three
now what we just drew here these three
are all equivalent but in certain cases
we'll see this in future videos you
don't have equivalent structures and
some of them might contribute more to
the resonance hybrid than others but
we'll see that in future videos